All right, good morning.
So today, we are going to talk
about what is both a basic
device in itself,
the amplifier,
and it also serves as a real
key example of both nonlinear
analysis and small signal
analysis.
So, today, dependent sources
and amplifiers.
So, let me first spend a few
seconds just pointing out to you
some of the key points from our
previous lectures.
I also want to point out that
each chapter in the course notes
has a summary at the end of it.
And if you take a quick scan of
the summary at the end of each
chapter, it highlights the major
takeaway points from each
chapter.
It stresses what's important,
and if you have to remember a
few things, what are those
things to remember?
So, to quickly review,
we talked about a few primitive
elements: resistors,
voltage sources,
and so on.
And by now, you should have the
facility to play around with
these device elements.
And then we talked about the
Node method, and this is kind of
the workhorse of 6.002.
When in doubt,
use the Node method.
OK, and this will work both for
linear circuits and nonlinear
circuits.
OK, so if you see a problem,
or if you see a situation in
real life that requires
analysis, then as a first step,
you should try to think of
whether you could apply some of
the key intuitive shortcut
methods, superposition.
One of my favorites,
the Thevenin method,
the Norton method,
or the method that involves
composition, that is very
quickly analyzing circuits that
have resistors in series and
parallel.
OK, so if you can apply one of
these quick, intuitive,
shortcut methods,
go do so.
If you can't,
then usually you can resort to
the Node method irrespective of
whether the circuit is linear or
nonlinear.
So the last week was focused on
the nonlinear method or
nonlinear circuits,
and we spent the first lecture
talking about a straightforward
application of the Node method,
which gave us a bunch of
nonlinear equations that we had
to solve.
In the last lecture,
we talked about the small
signal trick.
What we said is if you look at
the whole space of nonlinear
circuits, then within that
space, if we focus on small
variations, small perturbations
about an operating point,
then even the behavior of
nonlinear circuits in that small
regime would be linear.
So small signal method.
And as an example,
I showed you how I could take a
highly nonlinear device like the
garage door opener LED,
and using that,
build a pretty nice transmitter
that would transmit music.
And as long as we kept the
signal small,
and operated the device in a
region where its transfer curve
was relatively smooth,
and I biased,
or set the operating point
appropriately,
I would get a linear,
small signal response.
OK.
So today, we're going to do a
couple things.
We're going to look at
dependent sources.
And the reading for this is
section 2.6 of your course
notes.
And, the dependent source will
be a new element in your tool
chest.
We will also do amplifiers,
and amplifiers are in section
7.1 and section 7.2 of your
course notes.
So, before I begin with
dependent sources,
I'm just a huge believer in
motivating things with real
world examples.
OK, so let me start by
motivating: why we need an
amplifier?
Why do we need to do things
like this?
Or why do we even bother?
And, spend a few minutes really
getting you to appreciate that
amplification is fundamental.
OK, it's as foundational to
life as high fat potato chips
and stuff like that.
So, let's do some basic
examples here.
So first, let me talk about,
why do we need to amplify
signals.
Why amplify?
Why do we care about building
an amplifier?
So, an amplifier,
think of a little box,
and apply some sort of small
input.
And I get a larger output.
In this example,
this may be a voltage with a
swing of 10 mV,
and in this case,
the output might be another
voltage with a swing of,
say, 100 mV.
And commonly,
the amplifier,
in addition to an input and an
output, input port and output
port, may also contain the power
port, OK, so that I can apply a
power supply to the amplifier
because commonly as an amplifier
signal, I'm looking for a power
gain as well,
an increase in the power
provided by the output.
So, that's an abstract
definition of an amplifier,
and let's take a look at an
example of why we may need this.
So let's say I have a small,
useful signal,
and let's say the signal has 1
mV peak to peak.
And, I'm looking to transmit
the signal over a wire to some
other point.
But let's say that in this
environment, I get a bunch of
noise that is in a noisy
environment.
And in this environment,
let's assume that some noise
may get superimposed.
And if I have a 1 mV signal,
and 10 mV of noise,
then what I end up with at the
output is something that looks
like this.
And it's really hard to
distinguish my 1 mV signal from
that large amount of noise.
On the other hand,
if I do the following,
if I took the signal and passed
the signal to an amplifier,
and I amplified the signal to
be a much larger version of the
same signal, let's say in this
particular situation 100 mV peak
to peak signal.
OK, so I magnified the signal
by a factor of 100.
OK, let's say it's a linear
amplifier, I linearly amplified
signal to be 100 mV,
then in that case,
if I had a noise on top of
this, it's going to be less
discernible.
The signal will look like this.
OK, my 10 mV noise would add on
to it.
But, this is still pretty
decent.
I can still recognize the
input.
And so, this is one application
of amplification.
If I need to send something
from point A to point B as an
analog signal,
then an amplified signal is
less prone to noise attacks than
a small signal.
Not surprisingly,
a large number of devices that
are used in everyday life have
amplifiers built into them.
So, get a little cell phone,
and virtually every single cell
phone contains an amplifier.
By the way, this is an all
digital cell phone.
It's a Kyocera,
I forget the number now.
It's completely digital.
OK, although they say it's
completely digital,
it turns out that a significant
fraction of the circuitry is
analog, in particular,
so digital is sort of a
marketing term to say that
there's something special about
this.
But remember,
there's a bunch of analog
stuff.
So, here's my little antenna
from the cell phone.
OK, and typically the first
thing that happens to a signal
as it comes out of the antenna
in your cell phone is,
look at cell phone circuits,
or cell phone systems would be
something that looks like this,
OK, this, and may have a label
LNA.
If someone were to take a guess
at what LNA might stand for?
What's that?
Linear amplifier.
That's pretty good.
So that's LNA.
Close enough.
A is correct.
It's amplifier.
What does L and N stand for?
Low noise.
OK, so this stands for low
noise amplifier.
So, I get a really rinky dinky
small signal here,
and then the low noise
amplifier amplifies a signal.
And in real cell phones,
and for that matter,
in your 802.11b,
or 802.11a, or 802.11g wireless
cards, same thing.
Antenna, low noise amplifier,
and then you may have a bunch
of processing.
And commonly,
you have a bunch of analog
processing.
And then, you convert the
analog to a digital signal.
OK, I recall last week I asked
somebody in class here,
how would we transmit the
signal from point A to point B
without it being impacted way
too much by noise,
and he said,
oh, go digital.
Good point.
OK, so if I go digital,
I can transfer the signal
without noise being a real
factor.
But the analog to digital
converters need the signal
strengths to be a given value
before it can chop it up into
digital levels.
OK, so an amplifier is very
fundamental.
OK, and so in this case,
what may be a signal of a few
tens of microvolts to be
amplified to some large enough
value that it can be further
processed.
So, that's application of
amplification in the analog
domain.
Let me talk about amplification
in the digital domain.
So, that's in the analog
domain.
This amplification is in the
domain that I have both analog
and digital.
OK, and now let me talk about
amplification in the digital
domain, OK?
I'm going to argue that
amplification is absolutely
foundational to the digital
domain.
OK, the digital abstraction
would not occur if I did not
have basic amplification.
OK, and the next minute and 37
seconds I will prove that to
you, OK?
So, let's do so.
So, let's suppose I have a very
simple digital system,
and the system simply contains
a pair of inverters.
So, if I send a one here,
it's a zero here and a one
here, which is a very simple,
trivial, digital system.
And here's the input.
Here's the output.
And we said that for digital
systems of this sort to work,
they have to follow a static
discipline.
OK, our signals and our
circuits must follow a
discipline for them all to work
together.
And, the discipline we
described comprised of signals
adhering to certain voltage
thresholds so that all the
components in the system could
agree on what comprised a zero,
and what comprised a one,
OK?
So the way we did that was we
said that you would have a
threshold called VIH,
V input high,
and another threshold called
VIL, V input low.
OK, and we said that this
circuit must recognize signals
that are higher than VIH,
3 V for example as a one,
and simultaneously,
any signal that has a voltage
level less than VIL,
say, two volts,
should be recognized as a zero.
That was the input constraint.
On the output,
it had a similar set of
constraints, where we had
tougher constraints on devices,
where we said that the output
had to satisfy a output low
constraint, output high
constraint.
What this said is that for this
circuit to be called a good
digital circuit that satisfies
the static discipline,
signals that were ones here
should be recognized as such.
And if I am producing a one as
an output, then the signal level
should be higher than VOH.
Similarly, if the signal's a
zero, then it should be less
than VOL.
So as an example,
this may be 2 V,
this may be 3 V,
and this may be 4 V,
and this may be 1 V.
OK, so input,
I should recognize 2 V and less
as a zero, but at the output I
have to produce a very,
very low value,
1 V.
So, I have some noise margin.
So as an example,
say if I made a plot of the
input/output,
so I get my VIL here and VIH
here.
This is time.
This would comprise a valid
digital signal:
zero, one, zero,
one, and so on.
OK, now, I had a tougher set of
constraints at the output.
I would have VOL,
VOH.
So, at the output,
OK, I'm required to stretch the
ones and zeros to be further
apart from each other so that I
get noise margin,
and the corresponding signal
for our little circuit there
would look like so.
Right, if this is a valid
input, then this would be the
corresponding,
valid output.
OK, and need I say more?
OK, you can see that,
intuitively,
look, there's amplification
happening here,
and the reason is that VOL is
chosen to be less than VIL,
and VOH is higher than VIH.
So therefore,
the signal has to be stretched.
The signal has to be amplified.
OK, and what's the minimum
amplification needed for the
system to work?
The minimum amplification is if
I had a signal that looked like
this.
OK, that barely skimmed the
VIL, VIH level.
OK, so if signal were this high
peak to peak,
VIH minus VIL,
and what's the absolute minimum
signal at the output?
It would look something like
this.
OK, barely skimming VOL and
VOH, OK, so the corresponding
output level would be VOH minus
VOL.
OK, so this is the absolute
minimum amplification that my
digital circuit has to provide.
OK, and notice,
VOH is larger than VIH.
VOL is smaller than VIL.
Therefore, this quantity needs
to be greater than one.
OK, so I've shown you both a
simple, graphical,
intuitive explanation,
and this is a slightly more
formal proof that even the
digital circuit really requires
to have amplification built into
it, if it is to satisfy valid
static disciplines.
Yes?
Yes.
The question is,
is that the same as gain?
Good question.
Yes, the term amplification has
many, many variants.
You could say gain.
You could say amplification.
You could say increase in
signal strength,
and so on and so forth.
And in fact,
when talking about low noise
amplifiers, people sometimes
talk about having the low noise,
high gain amplifier at the
input stage.
OK, so let me pause there in
terms of motivation.
So, I believe I've motivated
every which way:
pure analog,
analog/digital,
and digital.
OK, so I've covered every
single base here.
And so, we need amplification.
OK, so let's look at how to
build a fundamental,
primitive device called the
amplifier.
Before we do that,
however, let me take a quick
detour.
It will be convenient for me,
as I show you how to build an
amplifier, to introduce a new
device, a new element,
called the dependent source.
OK, let me introduce a new
device for your arsenal of
devices, along with resistors,
You learned about a MOSFET,
a switch, voltage source,
current source,
and now a dependent source.
So, a dependent source looks
like this, OK,
has an output port,
and has a control port.
So, a dependent source in its
simplest form has two ports:
an input port and an output
port.
Remember, a port is a
convenient pairing of terminals,
and I apply signals to such
terminal pairs.
But this is a abstract diagram
for a dependent source,
and to get a little bit more
specific, let me show you an
example of a dependent source.
So, let's say,
here's my input,
and I label the terminal
variables for the input.
VC is the voltage applied to
the input, and IC is the current
into this terminal here.
And, here is the symbol for the
dependent source.
Much like a current source or a
voltage source has a circle
around it, the corresponding
symbol for a dependent source is
like so.
So this example,
for instance,
is a dependent,
current source.
I can apply the corresponding
output variables,
I0, OK, and I can say that the
current, I, is some function.
In this example,
I've designed the example that
the current through the current
source, I, is some function of
the input voltage or the control
voltage, VC.
OK, so notice that the current
through a current source,
the current through this
current source,
I, is some function of another
variable.
OK, in this example,
it's the voltage across its
control port.
Not surprisingly,
this device is called a voltage
controlled current source --
-- or a VCCS.
So, in like manner I can also
devise other forms of sources.
You can think of this is a
device where a voltage controls
an output current.
You can think of all other
combinations,
current controlling current,
voltage controlling voltage,
current controlling voltage,
and so on.
So, another example,
I give you another dependent
source, and in this situation,
my output current is controlled
by an input current,
VC.
IC rather.
And I claim that I for this one
is some function of a current,
IC.
OK, it's another dependent
source where the output current
for its output port is related
to the current,
IC.
And, this is a current
controlled current source.
OK, it's a current controlled
current source.
And, if I had lots of time on
my hands, and I was wanting to
kill time, I'd sit around
drawing for you,
other types of dependent
sources.
I would draw for you a current
controlled voltage sourced,
and I could also draw for you a
voltage controlled voltage
source.
OK, so that's an abstract
diagram for such a source.
And so, let's do a few examples
involving elements like this.
To begin, just so you can build
up your intuition,
let me start by doing a very
simple circuit,
involving an independent
current source,
OK, just so we can relate back
to what we've been doing so far.
So, let's say I have some
resistor, and I have a standard
current source with current I
nought.
This is an independent current
source.
Remember the circle?
And, some resistor,
R, and let's say I care about
the voltage across the resistor.
OK, so I have a current I
nought flowing through it.
So, I can very quickly write
down VR as, simply,
I0 R.
OK, it's the drop across the
resistor when a current I nought
flows through it.
OK, so this is what you've been
used to doing.
Correspondingly,
I can do an example with a
dependent current source.
And, as an example,
I'll use a voltage controlled
current source.
OK, a voltage controlled
current source is a dependent
current source whose output
current depends on the voltage
applied at the control port of
the current source.
So let me build a little
circuit.
OK, so here's my current.
And let's say it's VC IC for
the control port,
and similarly,
let's say my current I here is
some function of the control
port voltage.
And let's say,
to be specific,
there is some K over VC,
some function.
OK, there are a variety of
dependent sources that can be
built, and here's a hypothetical
device where the output current
is mathematically related to the
input in the following manner.
So, let me build a circuit of
the following form.
So, let's add the resistor,
R, and here's my circuit,
OK?
And, as before,
let me look to figuring out
what VR is.
So, notice that I have to
supply some voltage at the input
so that the output can depend on
the input because right now I
don't know what the input here.
So what I'll do is let me apply
VR over here.
OK, so let me make this
connection.
OK, let me make the connection
from here to here.
What I've done is I've applied
VR at the control port of the
dependent current source.
OK, and I often draw a circuit
like this.
This looks pretty messy.
I will often draw the circuit
like so: R, VR.
OK, short form circuit drawing
would look like this.
This is a complete drawing that
I show you the explicit
connections of the control port,
but oftentimes,
when the control port does not
have any other impact in the
circuit, you can eliminate,
don't explicitly show the
control port.
Rather, you can simply show the
dependence of the output current
on whatever circuit variable you
have in mind.
So, you can draw the diamond
like this, and see its current
is some function of VR.
VR in this is case is K divided
by VR, OK?
OK, so let's go ahead and
analyze this little circuit
here, and look at what this
might give us.
Our goal, as before,
is to find out the value,
VR.
So, in this case,
let's apply the Node method to
this node, and sum the currents
into that node to be zero.
OK, so sum the currents going
The current going down is
simply VR divided by R.
OK, and that is equal to the
current that is going out of the
node.
And so that is equal to F of
VR.
And I know that F of VR is
given by K divided by VR.
OK, a simple application of the
Node method.
So then, I collect VR's on the
left hand side,
and I get VR squared is K times
R, OK, and VR is simply the
square root of KR.
There you go:
I'm done.
OK, I've gone ahead an applied
the Node method to this,
and when have to figure out the
current here,
I simply reflect the fact that
it depends on VR like so,
and I just go ahead and solve
the circuit.
Remember, the workhorse of the
circuit industry,
the Node method,
when in doubt,
apply it.
It simply works.
And notice, this is a nonlinear
circuit.
OK, the dependence is
nonlinear, and I get the
response like so.
So, to plug in some numbers,
supposing K was 10 to the minus
3 amperes per volt,
and R was one kilo ohm,
then I can plug the numbers in
and the kilo here cancels with
the 10 to the minus 3,
and I get VR equals 1 V.
OK, this simply says,
if I build a circuit like this,
then this voltage here will be
1 V.
So, again, as long as you
remember that the dependent
source is simply another little
circuit element,
OK, and you usually draw just
the output port for dependent
sources, and reflect the way
that the control affects the
current, that'll suffice,
and you get,
through the application of the
Node method, the variable you're
interested in.
Let's do another example,
OK, of another fun current
source, a voltage controlled
current source,
and look at it this way.
So, let's say I have a
resistor, and I have a current
source, a resistor,
RL, and this goes to some,
I apply a VS here.
Remember this short form
notation; that's simply applying
a supply VS between that node
and the ground.
OK, and let us say the current
IV through the device is some
function of the current at its
control port.
OK, so I'm not going to show
you that.
But remember that the device
already looks like this,
that there is a control port
here.
I'm not showing that to you.
And let us say that I apply
some voltage,
VI, to the input port.
The reason we often don't show
the input port is for many
practical dependent sources,
the input has no other effect
on the circuit.
So, for example,
in this case,
the input has infinite
resistance looking in.
So therefore,
if I apply a VI here,
it doesn't draw any current
from VI.
I simply apply the voltage,
VI.
It doesn't affect the circuit
in any other way except in terms
of how it controls the current
ID.
So let's say the current ID is
some function of VI because VI
is applied at the control port.
OK, and as I pointed out
before, I oftentimes,
just for clarity,
just to show this dependent
source explicitly.
OK, so let's work the example.
So as I said,
I'm going to choose ID to be F
of VI, and let's pick some
specific parameters here.
Let's say it's K by two VI
minus one, both squared.
OK, and let's say this is true
for VI less than equal to one
volt.
And let us also say that ID
equals zero for VI less than one
volt.
OK, it's a dependent source,
and it can have various forms
of dependences on the input.
And, I just picked an example
of some hypothetical,
or as yet, hypothetical
dependent source,
the current through which is
related to the input using a
square law relation,
VI minus one all squared as
long as VI is greater than one.
And if VI is less than one,
then the current is simply
zero, it shuts off.
So, I can go ahead and apply.
So, let's say I want to find
out V0 versus VI.
So, I care about finding out
V0.
V0 is the voltage of this node
with respect to ground.
OK, so it's a slightly more
complicated circuit than you saw
up here, than you saw up there.
So, let's go ahead and do this
example.
Start by applying the workhorse
of the circuits business,
the Node method,
and let's start with doing this
for VI.
Let's first do it for VI
greater than one,
notice the behavior of this is
different for different ranges
of VI.
So let's first do it for VI
greater than or equal to one and
apply the Node method.
Node method says sum the
currents going into this node;
we know the voltage at this
node.
It's VI.
We know the voltage at this
node.
It's VS.
OK, the only unknown is V
nought.
And so, let's go ahead and
write the node equations for
that node.
So, the current going up,
let me simply equate the
current going up to the current
that has been supplied by this
particular node here.
And, that should equate that
the two of them should sum to
zero, the current going up plus
the current going down should
sum to zero.
So, I get V0 minus VS divided
by R.
That's the current going up.
Plus, the current going down
must sum to zero,
plus ID must sum to zero.
And ID is going to be K divided
by two VI minus one all squared.
That must equal zero.
Straightforward application of
Node method, current going up
plus the current going down at
this node should equal zero
because the total current
leaving the node must be zero,
OK?
So I can go ahead and simplify
this, multiply it throughout by,
I call this RL here.
So, multiply it throughout by
RL, and move all of this to the
other side, so I get VS divided
by RL, multiply it throughout by
RL.
I get VS at this side.
I take this term to the other
side.
This becomes a minus.
RL multiplies here,
so I get KRL.
That's the expression I get.
V nought is VS minus KRL
divided by two times VI minus
one all squared.
Let me put a box around this
because I will be referring to
this more times in 6.002 for a
variety of reasons than probably
any other equation on Earth.
OK, this is the first time you
saw it.
You saw it here.
OK, mark it down.
You'll smile every other time
you look at it in quizzes,
and you will find out why this
comes up very often in 6.002.
So, I'll just give you a few
seconds to savor this big moment
in your 6.002 life.
All right, OK,
so it's pretty simple actually.
I mean, there's really not
much.
A lot of this stuff is just a
plain old, simple application of
the Node method,
and things just fall out.
It's just so simple.
So, the V nought,
I apply the Node method,
I get V nought for this
nonlinear circuit.
I can also it for VI less than
one.
For VI less than one,
when VI is less than one,
what happens?
ID is zero.
OK, since ID is zero,
think of this as an open
circuit.
OK, so there's no voltage drop
across RL.
And, this voltage V nought is
equal to VS.
So, I like to see things in
pictures.
I'm not an equations kind of
person.
I'm much more of a graphical
So, let me draw a little graph
to show how V nought,
to see the form of V nought,
and then let's study that
little system a little bit more
carefully.
So, this is page seven,
and we plot V nought versus VI
for you.
And let's take a look at how
this really simple circuit
looks.
This has got nothing.
It's got an RL resistor
connected to a supply,
and a dependent current source,
and I apply some voltage VI at
the input.
It's a very,
very simple circuit.
So, let's see.
So as long as VI is less than
one, the output stays at VS.
OK, that makes intuitive sense,
right?
As long as the current here is
zero, this is like an open
circuit here.
If this is an open circuit,
then effectively,
V nought is simply the voltage
VS.
V nought simply appears here.
If you want to grunge through
KVL and KCL, go ahead.
VS minus RL times the current
is V nought, and the current is
zero so it's,
yes.
So, this is simply VS.
When VI goes above one volt,
fun stuff begins to happen.
OK, when V nought goes above
one volt, then this equation
applies because VI is greater
than one.
This equation applies.
And, when VI is a one,
one minus one is zero.
This term cancels out,
so this is VS.
OK, phew!
So, I start off here.
As VI increases,
what happens now?
this term here becomes
increasingly negative,
OK, subtracting from VS.
OK, so I get some behavior like
this.
V nought begins to drop.
And it makes intuitive sense,
right?
As ID begins to increase,
the voltage here will begin to
drop because I'm drawing more
and more current through RL.
I'm dropping more and more
across RL.
So more and more drops across
RL, so V nought begins to drop
too.
So, it looks something like
this.
I'll show you a little demo,
but my claim is that you have
just seen an amplifier.
Whoa.
You just saw an amplifier.
So, I snuck an amplifier by
you, OK?
So, I just snuck an amplifier
past you.
I'll show you why in a second.
So, let's take a look at this
waveform here.
Let's not worry about what
happens way down here.
We'll talk about that a little
later.
But, look at this curve here.
I claim there is amplification
in the following sense.
Focus on some change in the
input voltage,
delta VI, OK,
and for that change in input
voltage, I get some change in
the output voltage.
OK, for some change in the
input voltage,
delta VI, I get some change in
the output voltage.
And guess what?
In this, at least the way I
have drawn it,
delta V nought divided by delta
VI, if I can find regions of the
curve where this is greater than
one, then I have amplification.
OK, so what's that saying?
What that's saying is that if I
apply some voltage here,
OK, and I change that voltage
by a small amount from,
let's say, 2 V to 2.1.
OK, I am going to find the
output voltage.
Let's say I go from 2 V to 2.1
here.
OK, abstractly out there,
I might have an output that
goes from three to,
let's say, two V perhaps.
OK, so for a 0.1 change here,
I'm going to get a bigger drop
here, so from 3 V to 2 V,
giving me an amplification in
this little circuit.
OK, so we'll see this again and
again, and you'll really
understand it.
So, I have a small change in
the input, and I have a
corresponding larger change in
the output.
So, I've shown you an
amplifier.
I haven't shown you a linear
There's an extra charge for
that.
OK, that'll happen later.
OK, all I've shown you so far
is an amplifier,
and this happens to be a crummy
amplifier.
It's a nonlinear amplifier
because, notice,
this is not linear.
It's a nice little curve,
and so it's not linear.
But, I promised you an
amplifier, and I'm cheap,
and that's all you get for now.
OK, we'll see linear stuff
later, but for now,
I have a little amplifier.
So, let's do some real numbers,
and plot some numbers down,
and also look at a demo.
So, let's do an example.
Let's say VS is 10 V,
that the K is two milliamps per
V squared, and let's say RL is
five kilo-ohms,
OK?
So, let me substitute these
values into that equation,
and I get V nought is,
VS is ten.
So, it's ten minus,
KRL divided by two.
So, K is two milliamps.
Two milliamps times five
kilo-ohms is ten divided by two
gives me five,
and VI minus one squared.
That's what I have.
I just plug in a bunch of
numbers, and that's what I get.
So, what I'll do is let me just
do a little table for you,
and plot using real numbers,
simply plot those values for
you.